because you know
are you under Union that Indiana needs
to find a consistent Middleton that's
defiantly a sober screen rescreen and
[Applause]
screen he sets a wide body it's so hard
to get around him and the guy who is
shooting like Chris Middleton is
shooting the basketball tonight and
that's a double screen
[Applause]
purply so far this season only 10% of
Epona's threes have come from the
corners Middleton hits a triple it's a
nice job Chris Middleton 11 rebounds
after three quarters 42 to 31
[Applause]
I've been waits for the screen kind of a
slipstream I love this Thursday benefit
Chris Middleton was spotted up ready to
shoot it even though he's stepping back
a little bit right would be basically
would not come back to you on a high hop
true bounce nice fast break it
[Applause]
Nettleton for three Wow in the lane
militant knocked it away from the man
it's picked up by Henson two-on-one with
Brogdon now they come in it collided in
the kenneth still gonna go down here is
involved
and really the big three for ripping
stroke from the outside he's gonna see a
lot more connects to this puzzle to
pursue the whole Chris Middleton off the
dribble have to set the high screen for
Middleton and verse which that yoga John
Middleton tough shot tougher who to get
it just over the outstretched hands of
[Music]
Ross court three on the way they have
[Applause]
you've got to figure it out he waltzes
down the link and we pay our respects to
the late Robert Indiana we lost him this
year right down Main Street try to get
downhill he told sterling Brown you need
to have an impact as soon as you go in
Yanis always hesitant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three hits first he's blunt radon
triples brings that baby old for seven
and then Middleton does this the weights
were indignant don't wish to get there
the beaches defender on him well so that
it feels I got to stay with me McCallum
defended well by a Brockton force
training ground Evan Turner the
defense's possession they're forcing him
in with self to his first the team's
third and always San Antonio team
[Applause]
Middleton
[Applause]
hips back like Return of the Jedi
hiya lengthen now I go back to Charlotte
the last play
tonight they strip to the three for him
to start and now he hits the big three
in Malcolm Brogdon there's a great
Davenant
decision-making crit beggin for the
basketball and I think he'll glad so
they tipped it out right yes Lynn so did
a great job with the tapout would kept
it alive and Middleton wanted this shot
shattered with confidence kettle raladin
9,000 attempt so he as you can tell his
career pretty close great partner Chris
Millington in Toronto Wednesday on ESPN
the Bucks will fall to 16 and 8 9 & 8 no
f17 about Yanis Brogdon with a nice show
and go tried to thank them
Middleton around the world and a little
bit of sauce hey now that was pretty
that was pretty plug majeski up and I
watch Middleton down Oh little beanbags
ouch I [ __ ] just moved under 10
science scores and Chris Middleton and
you just feel like they've been hogging
that Lane and you would need to got that
list
[Applause]
three made by Melton three-point
opportunity he's behind the line he can
get four out of this couldn't be more
timely and a couple possessions ago DJ
Wilson had a wide open three to Miami
Heat defenders chose to stay in the lane
box out rebound it was broken when he
got here or when he went when fears
arrived he was broken handle ten hits
the three plus the fat wow that's a
big-time play right there stopping the
run aggressive he's lying and bond layup
if he'd get that step back he's going to
knock down a high percentage three-point
shot I lost Wednesday at Washington 114
Matt en la deuda gentlemen's games at
USC as a freshman for him to be shooting
36% in NBA the June 15th events
see that glucose or watch a replay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
miss Jin Yan escapes her be fair
five seconds to go Milton he gets it off
and counted with wound seven to go the
end of a high-scoring first half-hour
glad show drives his shield throws it
across the paintings picked off
Middleton gets it back however for the
jam miss Middleton's dunk off the loose
ball situation just picks it up high
percentage shot number 18 Moses Malone
Chris knocked that down yes but but
Moses Malone's getting the statue
getting his number retired by Philly but
all he wants on the perimeter along the
great foot speed touched at Middleton
over control that's a great job by
credit separation Shepherd watch Chris
Middleton driving left get him moving
that's the that's the key
[Applause]
go double flexes it's gone me three for
three and you're right back in it he's
pulling up he's right at that free-throw
line
he's got well 12 rebounds and 10 assists
his pass Middleton to Bludso's bucket
here the shot clock down to three
Middleton gets into the lane and his
floater is good the Bucks are 23 games
over 500 for the second time this season
look at Middleton fight off that
baseline and that's what I love about
the best shooters in the NBA moves out
animal here comes Middleton driving into
ciacco
back out to hero his triple is down
George Hill
the books shot clock challenged in his
possession deflection Middleton throws
it up and in my goodness that's an
all-star shots with the shot clock
winding down Middleton you saw that he
gathered straight that elbow out Dallas
is usually good for 20 most nights is
missing
another tick away this time little Timmy
Janus passion break cut down a spine for
trolling we've got the bill playing a
very prideful game right now 10 points
on 4 of 5 shooting for peel as Middleton
Spin City
plus the foul keeping an eye on
teammates Middleton / Bogdanovich well
done isn't it great to sit down with him
one-on-one time to allow Palace in to
get to his right and get a straight line
drive to the basket la défense Middleton
sees George Hill there both teams have
really put the stress on each other
- quickly as he was advancing in the
first quarter
to your point Middleton hits that one
for a dunk cell or point-blank
point-blank mate Utah has unleashed an
18-2 tune run before Chris Middleton
hits the three yeah six and he'll head
to the line
Middleton can do this and put you in a
tough position taking any chances as
Yanis is able to have her gown
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
beautifully done Middleton and one off
the glass see there's there's a Diallo
he's got to stay with Brook Lopez and
middle
[Applause]
Chris Middleton
fell down got up flat so the wood but
let's oh nice job presence of mine
Yun's dance chris is down there just
late get back on defense and she got it
so working against sexton the Bucks have
to move it around to the perimeter ten
on the shot clock
another three right through Chris
Middleton under two minutes in the first
quarter
stretch Middleton talk about masterful
that was a masterful bill
I sold prison with the Clippers lately
this is the ninth straight game that he
has scored ten or more points he has 19
feeling a big time here and like you
talked about it but just a quiet that's
it quiet because of the number of shout
attempts that is taken in decors and a
foul have an impacted offenses he really
is so polished sir actually first are
they not in points for chanting yes yes
the other but sad unannounced and
DJ Wilson from Middleton the heart flush
his heart Starbound beautiful job
Christmas Flair left hand dropped behind
the back number 2 DJ Wilson you run the
four good things that happen for you and
if you don't sprint back on deep
everybody's watching him then this mix
behind
defenders play
[Music]
don't swallow as for early points he
started the game 36 from 2000 this
season's and that is somewhat
significant because he would become the
second player in Bunch history with
consecutive 2,000 points season most all
season let's get it done let's just get
it done sit right here knocking on the
door that's another one of those little
seeds you don't want to play sterling
Brown Lopez lost it on the way up batted
it off the glass let's all working with
Middleton slow it down and find the
dispatches
[Applause]
find the mismatches little thing found
it it was his man
and then just up and over so hard for
defending the tinted on the move
wickedness moves the [ __ ] under fifty
percent at forty nine spot defense
that's often to hit narratives we'll get
back to Middleton for three and the
pucks take the lead he can get it he can
get him mismatch anytime on a switch
Boston has turned it over seven times
Middleton all put in traffic with the
left hand tell you Rozier almost ran
that down he'll turn against Haywood
eight on the clock where nobody else
Tawes on that possession but it works
for the Bucks first-time all-star Chris
Middleton going off his offensive
repertoire there
[Music]
[Applause]
and the way he's been shooting
[Applause]
he played by siakam
and that say awkward submarine Valjean
as he got around an injury nice wash up
by Danny but the offensive rebounds
right back to Middleton I said earlier
earlier Middleton has been the go-to
Middleton has to chase it fires and hits
well he knew that time was running down
we'll talk
[Music]
here's that shot by Pendleton could not
even look at the basket what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content